[Music]
the flashy arrival of a Justice League
member in theaters is joined by yet
another Disney Pixar money maker plus
the return of a Netflix Action Hero the
return of a popular sci-fi mystery
series and the return of one of the
latest Star Trek spin-off shows we've
got all the right elements coming
together on this week's what to watch
Bruce I could fix things you could also
destroy everything just kept me
happening
broke the universe speeding into
theaters is the DC film The Flash
without any more Ado we're happy to
report that the film is coming in fresh
at 68 on the Tomato Meter with 125
reviews with the critics consensus
saying the flash is funny fiddling
fast-paced and overall ranks as one of
the best DC movies in recent years right
on team DC another reason to get excited
especially if you're a Comics nerd is
that the elements of this film were
influenced by the flashpoint story arc
from the comics in 2011 which includes
an altered DC Universe with plenty of
Crossovers and when I say crossovers I
don't just mean the flash hanging with
another version of himself although that
will happen in this one no I'm talking
about the appearance of Michael Keaton's
Batman where prized from 1989's Batman
and 1992's Batman Returns which for the
sake of this film took place in an
alternate universe and for the sake of
reasons to watch if that doesn't put
your butt in a theater seat I don't know
what will we're talking about Keaton's
Batmobile and his batwing folks we all
live by one simple rule
the men's cannot mix
a pipe squished me all out of shape and
bringing more than just a little speed
to theaters is the animated film
Elemental this Disney Pixar original is
set in a place called Elemental City
where fire water air and land residents
all live together and a fiery young
woman named Ember begins to question her
beliefs about the world she lives in and
yes that all feels very much like a
Pixar movie which is a good thing and a
great reason to check it out another
reason to give this one a look and a
listen is because of The Talented voice
cast which is a mix of young Talent like
stars Leah Lewis Mamadou ache and more
established actors in supporting roles
like Catherine O'Hara Wendy McLendon
Covey and Joe para and if you're still
waiting for another element to help
persuade you consider the resume of
director Peter son not only did he
direct 2015's the good dinosaur but he's
also lent his voice to animated hits
like Ratatouille Monsters University and
light year would you survived
bought your way back
you just have to find out why
if you want both excitement and action
in streaming form this week look no
further than extraction 2 on Netflix get
it because the word extraction is like a
cross between excitement and action okay
anyway the first film from 2020 which
starred Chris Hemsworth and is called
simply extraction is a fresh 67 on the
Tomato Meter with a strong audience
score at 70 we can call those reasons
one and one a to slide your thumb over
to this sequel on top of that not only
does Hemsworth reprise his role as an
Australian Black Ops mercenary but this
time he will be reuniting with his old
Thor Ragnarok co-star Idris Elba oh
they're total buds plus since all these
reasons are coming in pairs or more
let's not forget about the Russo
connection as in once again Joe Russo
wrote the screenplay which is based on a
graphic novel co-written by Joe and his
brother Anthony Russo along with a
handful of other people
so that's what your documentary is about
the details are so awful it is
irresistible
I love it another strong streaming
option for you this week is the sixth
season of Black Mirror one of the show's
creators Charlie Brooker said they opted
against making a new season during the
pandemic to avoid being quote unquote
too depressing for audiences wow what a
thoughtful dude but we are definitely
glad it's back and the reason we're
celebrating its return from Hiatus is
because this Anthology series that
touches on Humanity's unease with the
modern world has turned in five fresh
Seasons not to mention an interactive
movie and a Christmas special oh what
plus you know Black Mirror keeps fans
always wanting more by using an array of
different stars to dive into the Techno
paranoia for season six some of those
names include Aaron Paul zazzy beats
Josh Hartnett Kate Mara and Michael
Sarah plus many more but you get it hard
job
puts us up against death
like it
we do have to face it and finally boldly
heading into a second season is the
series Star Trek Strange New World the
top reason to launch into this one is
that it's a spin-off from the Star Trek
Discovery series and follows Captain
Kirk's predecessor Captain Christopher
Pike as he navigates the Enterprise in
the decade leading up to the original
series how cool is that plus with a 99
certified fresh first season under its
belt it's clear critics are totally on
board with the show giving it praise for
quote recapturing the sense of boundless
discovery that defined the franchise's
roots end quote plus now is the perfect
time to come aboard strange new worlds
and get settled in cause a third season
was ordered back in March
well there you have it friends five
flashy picks to keep your viewing
options running at full speed that's how
we roll be sure to let us and your
fellow viewers know in the comments what
you did check out whether was on this
list or not remember to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh
foreign